all right guys bang-bang I've got a
special treat for you today
Igor's here and we have a lot to talk
about but uh I appreciate you taking the
time to record this during quarantine
yeah thanks for having me
let's just jump right in your background
you've spent a lot of time in technology
built a number of companies maybe just
gotta take us from the beginning to how
we get to today sure so I used to lead
the advanced multimodal research team at
IBM and when I was frustrated that they
didn't want to commercialize AI as fast
as I wanted to
ended up departing we founded a company
called Yap which was one of the first if
not the first AI cloud company Microsoft
ended up becoming a customer sprint was
a customer we had almost 50 million
users on the platform and then google
tried acquiring us as did Amazon and off
we went to Amazon land in 2011 and it
formed the nucleus of what everybody now
knows as Alexa the Amazon echo and these
experiences yeah so let's go back to the
IBM chunks I think a lot of people look
at IBM and they basically say you know
the Cubbies been around forever it's a
blue chin they've got hundreds of
thousands of employees like how exactly
does technology development happen
instead of a large company like that and
then obviously it led to some
frustrations from your ends you guys
might survey your own company maybe talk
to just about structurally how that
happens in a big corporation or in in
and look they're stewards of just some
amazing technology right the problem is
that we ascertained is that they
couldn't take the inventions and
commercialize them so that they could be
prepared for self-consumption for
interesting which is what's driving a
lot of this cloud adoption or even if
you look at the number of enterprise
software brands that got released into
the wild at the workgroup level and they
just tore it up right things like
Salesforce zoom that we're speaking on
here tableau in the like we're all
released at the workgroup level and they
and they made their way up no CIO see so
a CFO
had to sign off on on their adoption and
I think they had hadn't figured that out
because a lot of the software that they
create is unfinished right because it's
typically handed to their Global
Services team which then do a lot of the
customizations for for each individual
customer whereas if you look at what
Google and Amazon and other folks do
they write once and run everywhere and
minimize the number of customizations
that are required and that's led to an
upheaval in the tech provider space yeah
and then I guess as part of the exercise
to spin out and go do this was the idea
to end up building which recognition
software and kind of this AI cloud
knowing that these personal devices like
the Alexa's the Google homes etc would
kind of be the end state or was it more
just generalized we think this
technology is interesting let's develop
it and then we'll figure out the
consumer applications later now I think
we had a sense of the consumer
applications in fact in 2006 I already
had a prototype for what would become
Alexa right so I carried around on a
little flip phone where I could speak
into it and it was all cloud powered
meaning it would record the audio on the
device and then stream it up to a remote
server and I could do things like Google
searches I could send messages I can
find things location-based you know
little mini maps and things of that sort
so we already had a sense that I could
have something that could answer
anything including why is the sky blue
so that was the sense now a lot of folks
were saying we don't understand what the
business model would be to support that
and back then without app stores right
without smartphones without 3G networks
without any way to monetize this thing
people were unsure how we would create
absorption for the consumer space of
these technologies yeah and really I
guess the technology ends up being a
combination of multiple trends right or
technology developments and so you've
got machine learning you've got voice
recognition you've got some level of
artificial intelligence in there maybe
help us understand like is that a
Sequoia
so thing where one technology gets built
that's added to another or did you have
to wait until all of those technologies
reach a certain point and then you kind
of put them all together to actually get
the core of the technology well all
innovation as you know is nonlinear and
so none of it is ready at the same time
that's some some other function is it's
ready but people like us don't sit
around twiddling our thumbs waiting for
the perfect moment so what you're doing
is you're constantly iterating and as
you know best-of-breed
pieces snap in you go ahead and drop
that module in area engineers develop
something else you drop that module in
or your scientists develop something
else you drop that module in there so
you may have you know start with a
baseline acoustic model but then you
have a better one that fits the use
cases you may have a baseline language
model you drop in a better one that
supports your use cases whether it was
messaging voice mail processing call
mining a myriad of different use cases
at the time what was funny is as we were
fundraising in the 2007-2008 time frame
for our VC round a lot of people were
scratching their head saying I'm not
sure that I would use an AI assistant
but would you allow my other portfolio
company here I think some examples were
got voice you mail
ring ring central and some others would
you allow them access to your platform
and so by default we ended up becoming
this Twilio for speech recognition for
AI services as as an accidental
discovery if you will because the VCS
that we were pitching in someways
allowed their portfolio companies to
diligence us by becoming customers yeah
that's great when the the people you're
pitching end up doing business
development for you for sure that's
right and so obviously you kind of
describe what you had I'm a technology
front in 2006-2007 by the time that you
guys actually sold the Amazon what did
the technology do in yeah right like
what how far did you guys get before
that acquisition occur yeah so Brian
which is the new company's name was
actually the codename of the engine that
eventually became a nucleus of Alexa so
we knew that we needed to have a totally
independent stack because we didn't want
you know to be at the beck and call if
you will of other tech providers so we
had a little bit of a secret mission
behind the scenes and we built a a great
research organization inside of a
company which is not something that you
typically find in a start-up as we were
plotting complete independence and so it
was a state of our speech engine that
had you know some newfangled abilities
that even to this day we can't talk
about because you know a lot of people
think that you invent things and you
patent everything but you typically
don't there the there are certain core
capabilities you leave as trade secrets
for instance Google always was annoyed
that they published PageRank where in
hindsight they wish that they didn't
publish PageRank because it was such a
critical part of of their search acumen
yeah that makes sense
and I guess help us understand in kind
of layman's terms how exactly voice
recognition works right we use it every
day across all these different devices
but what's actually happening when I
verbally verbalize a command or a
question like how does the technology
ingest that and what's going on in the
background before it presents me the
answer yeah the the easiest way for you
to think about that is it's turning
audio files and converting them into
text in order to do that it takes the
audio stream and basically takes
everything that you say and converts it
into phonemes and then it clusters the
phonemes together in in a search to see
hey are these is this the right word for
this combination of phonemes and then it
goes to the next set of phonemes is this
the right word in the set of phonemes
and then it goes to the third set of
phonemes and says is this the right word
and then you have this concept above by
Graham's tried Graham's quad Graham's
and what have you where it says hey is
this sequence of words together does it
make sense or is there another
combination of words because every time
you have a word that it identifies it
also has something called an N best
meaning it has a list of alternative
words that it might be right so think of
a homonym like two is a t OT wo or t oo
well you need to know the context before
and afterwards just to figure out
which one it might be yeah it makes a
lot of sense and I guess then one of the
limiting factors to the accuracy is how
it ingest like how clearly can hear the
audio and then the conversion to text
and then what you're talking about here
is almost like the contextual
information that it's able to derive
from the other parts of the sentence
right and and and that's why you know
having a great engineering team paired
with a great research team is so
important right because the research
team works on the models and the engines
all the natural language everything that
you think about on the engineering team
we were blissfully lucky because we had
some of the original folks that worked
on the iPod engineering team worried
about our audio capabilities right our
audio stack and so they were able to
find disconnects where sometimes some of
the carriers that y'all use for your
cellular networks may have had certain
devices recording devices misconfigured
that were constraining the audio quality
which leads to poor accuracy and so we
had all sorts of routines to cleanse
audio and then feed the best
representation of your voice to the
recognizers and the models in order to
have the best accuracy
it took Google about ten years with all
these newfangled methods that you heard
of post-2012 to catch up to the level of
accuracy that we had ten years ago
that's how tight of a platform it was
yeah it's awesome and then what is it
like as you're going through kind of the
acquisition process you guys obviously
have multiple suitors at the table to
some degree like maybe talk through a
little bit how do you get in touch with
them is that like an ongoing
conversation or they just coming inbound
and what that process was like yeah none
of it starts from from a ground stop
you're building relationships with these
folks at the whole time you're on your
journey right so even to this day right
with with the current company that were
that we're operating you're always in
communications with the Cisco's the
IBM's the Google's the Amazons the
apples the Facebook's so on and so forth
all of the big brands that you can think
of it and even intermediate brands that
are up and coming
like the zooms the service nails and
everything else because your your member
of that ecosystem right so you're not
necessarily looking for investment
you're not necessarily looking for MA
but you're always looking for
partnerships scaling partnerships and
and what-have-you and it's just a normal
part of business as you know based on
the roles that you that yeah for sure
and I do not think I've ever asked days
before but you guys sold the company for
ninety hundred million bucks somewhere
in that range what was it like the
second you realized hey like we did it
rightly what was that kind of feeling of
okay this is real this happened like
what do you guys say to each other what
was kind of a feeling internal yeah I
know the number was never published
because we were on such a gag order with
Amazon because they never wanted anybody
to know that there are coming for speech
recognition and AI in a major way and
obviously they're one of the dominant
providers of AI services today but
frankly speaking nobody invents a
company wanting to sell it which is
counterintuitive because you think that
this is the way that value is unlocked
you're literally building a company like
the first days of Facebook or Google or
Amazon or any one of those and you're
building it to last you know to be
governed well to be innovative to hire a
world-class team and so much so in
reality no real founder that I know has
an exit fantasy or exists strategy
because why would they exit the thing
that they enjoy doing on it on a
day-to-day basis that they're you know
highly passionate about and so one of
the common themes that I've heard with a
lot of folks that do experience this
actually is they're actually quite sad
on the other side of it right because
here here they enjoyed working with this
team look look at the team that we've
built now right there
resilient folks they're supporting each
other they're doing it you know right by
customers and partners they're trying to
be relevant you know to this pandemic
and help where they can you you get to
work with these people day in day out
why would you want that to change
so that's that's the thing that people
don't don't tend to talk about
is that psychological change that
happens yeah it's super interesting
because it's very counterintuitive right
a lot of people would say hey the the
financial aspect of this should be
celebrated but I think a lot of folks
are less concerned with that it's more
of the concerns around well do I still
get to work on this and how is it going
to change I'm handing it over to
somebody else
in some cases etc so it's pretty
interesting there okay so you guys go
through the the acquisition to Amazon
obviously they end up taking that
technology and ultimately come out with
Alexa what's kind of the view kind of
post acquisition and over the last
couple of years as you've seen you know
kind of your journey and then this final
product of Alexa kind of the current
state of the product good bad
indifferent kind of how do you evaluate
what they've built I think it's good I
mean they you know what what the big
tech companies can do especially in the
consumer space is the they D risk things
as an interaction method because they
have other ways of supporting these
assets right because the majority of
their businesses are built on ads and
other forms of support and so they can
take these fantastic risks that expose
you know hundred plus million users to a
new way of being right in a new new way
of operating the business environment
tends to be more conservative right so
they kind of need things battle-tested
and then they need layers built on top
of those inventions right so security
layers governance layers manageability
layer so on and so forth and once those
things are proven in the consumer space
there ends up being a sonic boom where
these things eventually end up at work
and so look you know you had Facebook
and Twitter first and then you can have
slack and things and Yammer and in these
types of tools in the workplace you know
we have FaceTime before we really have
the you know the prominence of the web
X's and the zooms and and in the like as
well so the consumer space in some ways
is is the perma it will ooze if you will
in terms of adoption of certain types of
technology and that's what Silicon
Valley does very well and then and then
other folks come in and say okay now how
do we repackage this for business use
yeah makes a lot of sense you have
decided to go on the journey once again
and insert a new company you know
obviously we are investors in that
company as well maybe talk a little bit
about just kind of the problem said that
you saw in the market and and why you
wanted to go bang your head against the
wall again and build a company right and
it wasn't a decision Brian I mean again
I would I would consider there's a
there's an art to sight in science to
business that's entangled together right
and and to startups in a way and so it's
think of yourself as a writer as a
musician as a as a painter as a sculptor
this literally hit me like a ton of
bricks and I actually ended up trying to
give the idea away right so I called
buddies and Amazon and I said hey I just
you know thought of a new way that
that's going to be a breakthrough for
how AI he's done and they're like oh my
gosh get this funded and we resign and
join you and I dropped the phone like a
hot potato I'm like oh my gosh I don't
want another startup it's crazy talk and
then I picked up the phone and called a
buddy of mine that worked on Watson and
he's like hold on let me transfer you
over to the the CTO and I started
telling him what my idea was and I said
hey you guys should steal this and put
this in Watson I think it's going to be
a breakthrough going forward and he's
like I'm in and I'm like what do you
mean you're in you know imagine you know
in Hollywood how they have that dolly
zoom where you get goosebumps because
the backdrop you know falls back that's
the moment that I had this guy's
world-famous help stand up the Watson
division and he's never you know gone to
Google or Amazon or any of these places
or any startup when they approached him
but here you know this idea is big
enough where he's finally able to take a
risk with his current credibility and
then sure enough I called you no friend
that was working at Cisco reporting to
the CEO and he said yeah this is big and
so in some ways it's it's the reluctant
hero trope that you see in Greek
mythology in some ways and and I think
that's how you can tell that a company
was authentically founder a
right it wasn't just hey you know let's
go make some money no it was like hey
here's this idea that I can be sure and
I can pitch a hundred investors and even
if 99 of them say no my intuition and my
spidey sense is screaming on all
cylinders saying hey this is a big deal
especially since it's battle tested and
vetted by you know some amazing folks
that work in these amazing brands
including yourself right and the
experiences you had so that was that's
what the initial process was like got it
and then what was that original idea I
guess we didn't announce it yet and
we're gonna we were thinking of
announcing it at the Wall Street Journal
future of everything event in May but
that got rescheduled until the fall
timeframe so we're kind of we're going
to hold it back for a while
it'll be surprising and not surprising
all at the same time when we get it
revealed but it isn't in heady trials
now we even took investment from a
consortium that includes 18t goldman
sachs ups delta airlines and several
other folks New York Stock Exchange
Stanford University's an investor so we
have great backers that are that
certainly helped get us product market
fit and that's something that I would
suggest to anybody involved in startups
and I don't care where you are in the in
the food chain you know to have you know
great folks part of the journey from the
get-go to help you you know figure out
exactly how you're gonna package price
it you know exactly what they what they
need in what order in your roadmap is is
all important yeah how I go about
finding some of those early you know
kind of customer / research partners if
you go to some degree given that you
know there's tons of these big companies
but they're getting inundated every
single day with the newest shiniest toy
the latest request except like how do
you break through that noise and get
them actually to work with you yeah and
and that's why I think you know being
involved first of all your backers right
our backers constantly have corporate
development base and I have to give them
a
crédit you know great Croft partners
does that out of New York in LA
you know revolution does that at times
digital alpha has their own portfolio
that we're tending to bootstrap labs and
the rest so remember whenever you take
investment it comes with networks that's
actually more important than the money
that you're getting from these folks of
course you need their investment in
order to make payroll but more important
than that are we as we sit down and look
at who who's going to be on the cap
table and on the journey with us as well
it's what networks do they bring to bear
right because you're using gravity
assist whenever you saw these networks
together and it's irrelevant whether
they're fund or even into individual
investor right you're weighing each one
of them to say all right now you're part
of this journey how you know how are we
going to help us help you in in some
cases so it really isn't just you know
you know one thing right so you'll take
one investment from engage Ventures down
in Atlanta for instance and they have
ten different brands associated with
them you'll take an investment from
plug-and-play ventures in Silicon Valley
and they have a mess of brands that are
associated with them and in rinse repeat
with all of them right they all have
those connections and that's normal
whether you're running a florist shop
where you're running a startup you're
consistently looking at your customers
and partners and your backers for the
network's that they provide yeah and I
guess as part of this specifically in
the artificial intelligence and voice
recognition space how are these large
corporations doing and kind of the
innovation front right are they actually
making progress we see a lot of times
kind of a lot of headlines and
announcements and all this stuff but do
we see the progress outside of maybe the
Google and Amazon's that you would
expect or they may be ahead or behind
schedule of where maybe they should be
and that's always a touchy question
right from from our vantage point living
in the tech industry and weighing their
progress if you will but know this right
we may be really good at tech but
they're really good at flying planes if
they're really good at logistics they're
really good at operating banks they're
really good at all of these running
hospitals right so in some ways we
unfairly drug
to say hey you know what's your text act
looked like and do you have the latest
you know fangled you know chat AI
chess-playing thing or can you win it go
and do all of these other things sure
they may not have that but you know they
also know how to do all of these other
things to clothe us and feed us and move
us right that we don't know all right we
don't know how to build cars and planes
and all of these other things so I tend
to be respectful where where we show up
and say of course you guys wouldn't have
this because you're not a tech company
you're this other company and you have
all of these things that I don't have
and I need you to create a uniform unity
and and and that becomes a respectful
dialogue where we can play on each
other's strengths then yeah I guess it's
really interesting to when you when you
kind of break it down to the tech
companies that are building technology
just cause you have technology doesn't
this show me you have a product that can
go to the end consumer and serve you
know hundreds of thousands or millions
of people whereas many of those large
companies to your point they're experts
at kind of the whole package right the
final product is successful we're trying
to accomplish yeah and and they're
iterating as well right and they frankly
speaking based on the breadth of their
operations they are looking for things
that are battle tested right so they
care about the security of these things
because obviously we have you know
never-ending cyber attacks from all
sorts of non nonsensical folks out there
that like kicking sand castles down
instead of building them and and there's
many other attributes that they need
before they can adopt innovations yeah
let's talk a little bit about kind of
the general state of some of these
technologies so let's start with the
voice recognition in general kind of
give us an update as to where that is as
an industry and then kind of how you see
that developing over the next ten years
or so
yeah that's Minh dedup in a place where
it's more of a commodity now than in
table stakes for each of the major cloud
vendors so that's where it is today I
mean you can still be surprised by
certain applications of the technology
so for instance everybody assumed that
Texas speech was commoditized but in the
last week Google announced a novel
implementation where to backfill video
conferencing they actually took
portions of your invoice synthesize it
and they would insert them phonemes into
these video-conferencing feeds so that
you wouldn't have dropouts for instance
so you have these sort of little
applications that are moving the ball
forward but none of the grand big bang
style innovations anymore in that in
that particular field especially post
2012 so it's easier than ever to build
new languages obviously you know you
need to have a clean signal and do as
best as you can now you match models and
you pair it with machine translation and
at some point in time you'll you'll
expect where you could be an interview
in in in Russian in Chinese and French
and and talking to me and in your
earpiece you'll hear it in your native
language and vice versa but you know
there's still some areas where we're
language processing is still a little
bit iffy and that's all the metaphors
that we tend to use and and the jest
that we tend to use and the fact that
language is constantly evolving with
slang and so that's a never-ending part
of the work but the big breakthroughs
are are elsewhere nowadays yeah
one of the things I've been very
surprised that both positively at some
point and also negatively is podcast
transcripts right just having done so
many of them everyone in their mom has
come to us and said hey look at you know
we've got this tool that can basically
take the audio recording transcribe it
and the best ones are still like the
googles of the world right I mean people
who are specifically focused on podcast
audio to text they're just not very high
quality right and what ends up happening
to your point is either one they're too
literal right so every time I say the
word right like and um and all these
things get kind of ingested in and so
you get kind of an on clean version or
they just miss words right and it's
actually the conversion from audio to
text and so that's been pretty
surprising but then it does it on the
other side it's not as surprising
because Google probably has one of the
best ones from what we see well because
they were incentive to create one of the
best ones right because they actually
developed it to upper
on YouTube so that they can figure out
what was in the video so that they can
pair the best ads right so where there's
a will there's a way
right there are basically two major
places where media mining you know gets
perfected one is in the ad space and the
second is in the intelligence community
monitoring you know television
broadcasts in the case of voicemails for
instance one of the things that we
discovered is that you know when we used
to leave more voicemails and there were
a lot of voicemails on our previous
platforms we would rewrite a spoken
English into written English and part of
that was to remove those pause words
like you mentioned the ohms and AHS and
things of that sort
yeah super interesting machine learning
what uh what's kind of the lay of the
land or you know a state of where that
technology is and then how do you see
that playing out over the next ten years
or so yeah I think it's more than
applications of it right so in there is
a lot of work being done in that space
certainly in that academic environment
but you have to let me relate it to to
the past so according to be Madeleine
Wright is a fantastic school for speech
recognition and they have this academic
engine called Sphinx but for the most
part you know it's there for anybody to
download but you can't really put that
into into production right it doesn't
have the accuracy the scale in their
resilience that's in an optimization is
necessary to ever be put in in ahead a
large-scale implementation right and so
it's the same thing
right you may be hearing about all of
these advancements in in deep learning
and in natural language processing and
what-have-you but in order to take that
work that research and all the ideas
that you're hearing and actually put it
in such a way and package them so that
they could be consumed by these
large-scale enterprises with you know
tens of millions or hundreds of millions
or billions of transactions per month
that's a totally different thing and
frankly you have to start from scratch
in in many places yeah and I guess as
people go to build that debt that seems
to me to be one of the technologies
that's going to be core to every
industry right and it's just the longer
that we have soar one data sets through
these machine learning models the models
will get better but also
the insights that were able to glean
from this and you'll actually see almost
like an acceleration of the impact the
longer we go into the industry right
yeah there's basically three main places
you would place AI technology in in the
workplace right in one hand it's
analytics right measuring what you do
right the second is actually doing this
thing that you do right so workflows
right so powering all sorts of workflows
and the third is all manners of human
language technologies right because
humans are an important part of these
workflows and measurements and as a
result there has to be easy ways to
onboard their intelligence and their
abilities as well so those are the three
main areas that we see AI applied in
business yeah and now you're
interchanging some what the terminology
artificial intelligence machine learning
and there's a lot of people I think that
say hey look machine learning is kind of
the foundation for artificial
intelligence there's other people who
use them interchangeably like how do you
think about the either the difference or
the similarities between those two
really vernacular are used to describe
something that that is quite similar
yeah I guess there's a running joke
right AI is is what you tell the press
and m/l is what you tell practitioners
so that's the reality of it but people
like me never called it AI right it's
just something that started taking off
just like cloud as a word started taking
off are you kidding me I was stumbling
oh you know in our marketing team last
time was stumbling over ourselves we
didn't know how to call our hosted
speech recognition or client server or
any of this stuff and then and then
clouds started getting used and we're
like okay it's it's a cloud it's a cloud
service that's what it is software as a
service SAS that's what it is
and so in in some cases it's different
words describing the same thing for
different audiences yeah super
interesting and I guess then what are
some of the applications for this that
you're most excited about right in terms
of a hold constant the assumption that
technologists will continue to do what
they're best at they'll build the
technology will improve we'll get to
some of these end states that I think
people have had
been calling for for a while but where
are the applications that you think have
either the biggest impacts in the world
or that you're most excited about oh my
god there's endless endless applications
right it would be nice not to have
disinformation right it would be nice to
have smarter chat BOTS it would be nice
never to be on hold as you call into a
contact center and potentially have an
AI deal with stuff where we don't have
to reintroduce ourselves every time we
get a human on the other side it would
be nice to actually find the things that
we're looking for right and actually get
answers instead of a list of documents
it would be nice if the right
information was was sent to us you know
if we're morning person or a night
person so there's everywhere you can
think of you know there's there's
opportunities for AI and as Bezos said
this is first pitch 1st inning time
right we haven't even seen all the
places where it can optimize things and
for all the folks that are that are
worried about AI removing you from the
workforce you know and I know we're in a
challenging time where a lot of folks
are going to be losing their jobs and
it's gonna take a while until you know
we can literally reboot the economy but
there's more work than there are people
right and there's no more work that we
have machines and these algorithms are
still in their nascent stages as well so
we have we have plenty of opportunities
in front of us I tend to trend towards
an optimistic view of humanity and
technology working together to solve
these these problems yeah the part to me
that in that entire debate it's just
like this is not a new problem set right
I mean it used to be what 7080 percent
of people who are farmers right oh my
god you know what's gonna happen when
there's no when there's no need for
humans to do all of the farming and what
it actually ended up doing is humans as
a whole became more productive and they
started to actually use their
intelligence and kind of ingenuity to
drive innovation in other areas that
have a broader impact than just farming
right and I think that's somewhat
similar here is a lot of the
applications I've seen are going after
more the repetitive work right rather
than going after replacing lawyers or
you know things that humans are
innately better at the machines but
maybe you're seeing something different
yeah look look we had record low
unemployment you know until this
pandemic hit right so and yet with all
of this advanced technologies why did so
many of us you know have these jobs
certainly the jobs you and I and many of
our peers have weren't even a vision a
generation or two generations ago as
well and in there there's a lot of
arrogance for us to think that as even
our jobs get displaced that there aren't
new ones that come and take their place
in a generation or two we think that we
would know everything and we sound as
silly as the head of the Patent Office
you know around the turn of the last
century who thought that everything that
could ever be invented has been invented
that's uh that's pretty obnoxious
statement all right some time talking
about security for a little bit so that
the first is any time that you start to
have machines gathering lots of data I
think people are just worried about like
hey where's the data gets stored how do
you make sure it's secure how does that
get treated who does get shared with etc
how do you think about so the best
practices there and like at what level
of maybe awareness should people have
given these certain devices like you
know the Alexus in their homes Google
homes etc listening versus not listening
and all that yeah and that's why we have
to give the Apple team a lot of credit
right if you look at how their
architecting you know how they're going
to find things or in their architecture
for how they may be you know showing if
if somebody that had that virus cross
paths with you or not all right they're
really looking for ways of you know how
do you have your cake and eat it too
right so how do you have the the power
of technology to help you in in certain
regards by finding things or making sure
that you're not getting sick while at
the same time preserving your your
privacy and so I think people are being
a lot more thoughtful towards
architecting ways of essentially putting
bumpers around what you're sharing with
brands because I think even Facebook
right you know everybody's
in the corner to say all right and we're
not going to have this unfettered access
anymore
and you know we need a lot more trust
between us and our users as well
otherwise our users gonna go elsewhere
yeah what about the the debate around is
AI evil or not right which i think is a
funny debate in the idea of my
technology evil or not but there's
definitely people who would argue
artificial intelligences the greatest
risk to humanity and there's others who
would argue it's you know the most
beneficial thing that could possibly
happen I guess how do you just think
through that trade-off and do you give
any credence to the whole you know AI is
evil or is a big threat to humanity
right so that's that's like you know
trying to project morality to a hammer
right if you put a hammer into Bundy's
hand versus Jimmy Carter's you're gonna
have two different outcomes right Jimmy
Ted Bunny's gonna harm somebody and
Jimmy Carter is gonna build you a
Habitat for Humanity so it really is III
would not be looking at a form of
technology and automatically assuming
it's it's positive or negative I mean it
has no such spin if you will right it's
it's really what are you going to do it
with it right how are you going to apply
it in some cases it's it's going to
affect your privacy in other cases it's
going to help you hunt down vaccines so
it really depends on how you use the
tool yeah and do you think there's
things that we can do to maybe not
prevent but at least disincentivize the
negative use cases right kind of to your
point of if the technology falls in the
wrong people's hands or supplied in the
wrong way or they're things that can be
done to try to Shepherd us away from
that or is it just like other
technologies where you know bad people
are going to do bad things and good
people are going to do good things yeah
I think it organically it meets its end
if you will right where the majority of
people are going to be using it for
positive means because the community in
the market was would essentially
not reward negative uses of this
technology now it doesn't happen
overnight
but certainly there's there's no reward
for it in the long term yeah and we're
talking I think the applications of
artificial intelligence machine learning
voice recognition etc in what I'll call
kind of the current state and short to
medium term I think one of the long-term
implications that people are paying
attention to our long term applications
is things like neural link etc we're
actually start to merge the
computational power with the human body
and so there's applications that have
been discussed of literally taking it
putting in your brain all the way to
some people would argue you know
something like an Apple watch is
starting to get closer and closer air
pods etc how do you just think about
kind of the meeting of those two things
with such powerful technology augmenting
humans in some way yeah that's an
interesting one look we're worried about
disinformation in our news feeds right
in in Twitter and Facebook and stuff
like that so once the machines are
blended too into our minds are we
actually the ones voting for the people
that were voting for or is there some
undue influence that's being applied
towards you know you know parts of our
mind it's gonna be an interesting debate
you know to see where we end and where
they begin and then how do we ensure
that it's our our influence that's
creating these decisions and it's not
some sort of external influence that's a
tough one I mean it's hard enough for us
to eat information responsibly now when
it's separate from us and and so that's
uh those are new issues that future
generations are going to have to confirm
yeah and I guess it really begs the
question of like where is the
opportunity for something to go wrong
right because there's what data are you
collecting then how are you actually
categorizing the beta how are you
analyzing the data and then like what's
kind of the output of that entire
process and you know there's a lot of
people who frankly it scares the [ __ ]
out of them if Google and Amazon and
those companies are the ones doing that
stuff and kind of feeding them the
information or doing the analysis and
there's a lot of people who say wait a
minute
they're the smartest
you know kind of on a on a holistic
basis and so we'd much rather have them
do it rather than you know Joe Blow in
his basement who is kind of untrusted
unchecked and can kind of do whatever he
wants without any transparency yeah
that's the paradox right I mean it's
sort of like a comic book character
right be here long enough and you become
a villain right so we all remember the
nascent stages of the the googles and
the Amazons and the Facebook's and
everything else where they were
considered heroic for helping you know
communities reach each other right users
you know far-flung throughout the globe
to be able to communicate with one
another to find any sort of information
and now you know we have this new
situation where they're they're viewed
as the villains because they're so
dominant successful and they employ so
many folks and they have undue influence
on political processes and the like so
you'll have new upstarts but you'll also
have the incumbents being part of that
yeah for sure
and I guess the big question most people
have is just like how did these
technologies impact my life and you know
it's amazing that the Alexa is the
Google Holmes have all even Siri
have kind of infiltrated in a very
consumer friendly way people realize hey
look this is super helpful it does
provide me solutions but then I always
joke and say and then they say echo
Boston Dynamics robot running through
the forest and they're like holy [ __ ]
yeah the robots going to kill us all and
so it's really funny how I think
people's perspective is driven by the
use cases that they have and also what
they see information online drives how
their interests always with the
technology and in in some ways it's it's
scattershot and you know for every
positive use of technology you'll read a
negative 1 and positive 1 and negative 1
and and you're going back and forth like
a yo-yo on this is good for us or bad in
some ways you know we can't predict all
the good that's going to happen and it's
going to be surprising and we can't
predict all the bad that's going to
happen and it will surprise us as well
certainly nobody you know coming outside
of New Year's Day expected you know
everything to turn out the way
that it did in the first half of of this
year and and hopefully we have pleasant
surprises in front of us just not
unpleasant surprises - yeah one of the
other things that really fascinates me
around this whole space is the idea of
creating automated content but doing it
in Reverse right so we talked previously
about voice recognition being in fear my
voice and it gets written to text
there's analysis done etc but going in
Reverse being able to either take a book
let's say and turn it into an audio book
without a human having to sit there and
read it but it sounds like a human right
it doesn't sound like the robotic voices
that we've heard in the past or even you
know take a nightly news segment right
be able to kind of ingest all this
information then present that
information back just like a newscaster
would do we see it kind of the early
signs of that stuff actually being
present and if so like how long does it
take for us to get to more of that like
utopian world but I think everyone is
kind of intellectually curious about but
it doesn't know if it's actually
possible yeah there's a really neat use
cases for that right you had a whole
collection of natural language
generation startups that would take
financial news for instance so not all
publicly traded companies have analysts
covering them actually the vast majority
of them don't and so it would actually
take the bits and pieces of financial
information that that were delivered to
regulators and automatically generate
news pieces for those folks in order to
approximate the type of coverage at the
analysts were doing so again that's an
example of not enough humans and there
was no ROI for humans to do that work as
you said before it was repetitive they
did that for sports coverage right so
again the press doesn't cover every
single game but it would nice it would
be nice to have a natural language
version of the outcome of these
different matches and what-have-you and
that's what that technology was able to
do and like you said you know for every
you know New York Times bestseller where
you can get samuel l.jackson to read it
there's plenty of other books and
content that it would be nice to have in
an audio format why for accessibility
purposes you know you know for people to
listen to while they're while they're
driving right if if
this interview was just in written
format it would be nice to listen to it
if if it's something that you cared
about and you were you know driving on
the interstate for three hours the unity
recline site so that's that's where the
technology really fills in the blank if
you will again for highly automated
things where we're only automation can
help backstop something and make it
affordable so that you have access to a
different way of consuming content yeah
let's say I want to talk about here on
this technology for a move on is the
education right so obviously one of the
ways to accelerate the development of
all of this is to get more people
educated on the technologies and get
them building and innovating what do you
see in kind of the talent pipelines and
is it better for feet people who are
interested in this to go get trained
kind of classically in the traditional
education system or is this more of a
get on YouTube watch some videos and if
you're really dedicated you can teach
yourself the skill set that's necessary
I think it's honestly it's all of the
above if you're truly passionate about
the work you're gonna be tired less and
you're gonna consume everything you can
think of visa vie formal informal
education I've heard you know some of
the things that go and do you know good
entrepreneurial teams is whether they're
tinker's or not so they're tinkering and
they're honestly interested in in the
work before it becomes famous for
instance or it becomes lucrative you
know the majority of our team have been
working in the AI space one before it
was called AI and two four decades
before there was any any resources you
know being applied to it those are the
folks that you want involved on this
journey because you know that they just
love the work and anybody that loves
work by the way it doesn't even matter
if it's startups you know if you're the
best plumber in the world the best
electrician in the world the best cook
in the world you can tell you know when
when we look at your work right and I
think it we have to be a lot more
respectful of the different roles that
people have in society and say hey
everybody's work has value it's not just
the AI people it's not just a start-up
people it's not that just the bankers if
everything in fire is on all cylinders
and everybody does the best work
possible that's how you can have any I
by the way you can't have AI without
water
alright something has to cool all of
these technologies that do that you
can't have AI without electricity
there's all of these other things that
go into it by the way you can't have any
AI without feeding the people that are
creating these things right so if you're
a farmer you are actually part of AI if
if you're in logistics you are part of
it we're all part of developing these
technologies by the way just like we're
part of you doing your work as well and
so I'm kind of tired of of these
politicians trying to separate us from
each other when we actually have to work
on all of these things together by the
way that's how we did the moonshot
that's how we won the Cold War and
that's how we'll solve the pandemic and
so enough of that nonsense that we see
in the political sphere yeah in terms of
crypto anything there that you've paid
attention to or any thoughts on Bitcoin
or other cryptocurrencies yeah it's it's
it's interesting right because I don't
know how to solve the beginning or end
of it right in in the case of
decentralization it's it's it makes a
lot of sense right for for objectively
to look at it and then say no nothing
can have influence on the value of this
thing other than itself right and then
on the on the flip side though as you
look at this pandemic you see because we
do have that centralization that they're
able to apply certain stimulus in
different places where you know imagine
trying to do that with Bitcoin where we
can say hey you know what
now we're gonna reallocate Bitcoin to
all of the caregivers out there
literally all the doctors and nurses and
this and that or all the people that are
out or the work now we're gonna allocate
portions of the blockchain over to them
to make sure that they can feed
themselves right and and and pay their
rent and utilities and stuff like that
so I don't know how to solve the pro and
con because both architectures have
their place right for depending on on
what the environment looks like right in
some case obviously now we're worried
about rampant inflation because we don't
agree with all the ways that they're
spending this money right because I feel
like it's a shotgun approach right
instead of being targeted we're in
Iceland for instance everybody was
up for three weeks we had door-to-door
testing right they were able to find
half the folks that tested positively
were asymptomatic those folks were asked
to stay home perhaps another couple
weeks and and they can have a measured
way of rebooting their economy if you
will that would be a nice way to use
centralization and it would also be nice
if if they would say all right we're
gonna backstop the economy for three
weeks we're gonna freeze the stock
market so we don't have opportunists
hedge fund managers that are shorting
everything and causing disaster for our
industries and then we get everybody
eighty percent we could get the economy
back to eighty percent and then the
remaining folks that are still ill at
home we apply all the resources there
and then we bring them back online in
the succeeding three weeks that's the
right way to do it now these politicians
have no problem coming to us
door-to-door and shelling for votes but
nobody's knocked on my door to do a test
and nobody's coming to our doors and and
doing an N Abati's check and nobody's
gonna be coming to our door to give us a
vaccine so I don't know what's going on
there because frankly speaking I think
the economy would be in a better place
if we had very deterministic and
scheduled items for how we're we're
mediating these problems and so I think
this is why people are curious about all
of these new assets a new new way of
essentially having a financial system
because of the mismanagement that we see
in in other places now if you want to
apply you know centralized union of
stimulus fine but then don't start you
know you know firing Inspector General's
they're supposed to be watching how we
manage these funds yeah it's the data I
just looked at so it's the weekend of
April 12th or so is that there's still
less than three million tests that have
been administered in the United States
which means you know less than 1% of the
population has been tested and so really
that brings two problems right one is
you can't do anything that you just
described because we don't know who's
sick and who's not whether there's
symptomatic or not and so it's really
hard to kind of go back or at least try
to go back to the economy turned on
because you basically have to over
rotate or be overly
but to is then you're basically looking
at bias data on the testing that you
have to write because you know let's
call it eight are 2.2 2.3 million tests
that have been done a high percentage of
those are people who thought that
they're sick right so they go in and you
get kind of skewed data there and I
think the thing that this is really open
my eyes to is you'd like to think that
experts in general their economic or
health experts or government officials
they understand simple things like you
gotta have good data to make good
decisions and you know just very very
basic stuff and you see some of the
comments that are being made
you know both public and private market
ears like what the hell is going on
right why are we making these big
sweeping decisions when we had tested
you know 200,000 people and 80% of them
were possible I don't think that's
really the you know indicative of the
entire country but the separation we
just don't know right until you get
better testing you just don't know what
the data is I don't think it's the
experts I think experts are experts in
all fields like I said before if I have
a leak in my basement I'm not the expert
a plumber has an export if I have a
short-circuit
electricians an expert we all need to be
respectful of experts in these in this
different fields I think what happens is
the political process essentially mutes
the voices of these experts and facts
week we can't land something on the moon
without facts facts matter right and
objectively if you look at the financial
system maybe we need a hybrid approach
right you have this backstop out of a
mutable blockchain where you can't screw
with the story value it is it's there
it's immutable you own those assets and
then you have a separate portion of the
economy that is under more centralized
control so they can go in and and and
and smooth out the rough edges if you
will right it's it's using all of these
assets are at our disposal but I think
makes a lot of sense all right yeah for
sure and before I finish up I always ask
couple rapid-fire questions and they
should ask me a question to end it but
what is your favorite book ever
Asimov's foundation as a most foundation
it was just a fantastic tome I remember
reading it in a monastery by candlelight
which was I
given about how fantastical it was in
terms of saying hey if you knew math you
could predict the future and so now if
you look at the world that we have now
with all of these predictive models if
you will just like the ones that you
were talking about it's come to pass
right so you know again this is why we
have to be attuned to art not just
science fiction right art in general in
some ways is just a different language
for the things that we do and by the way
that's why I'm not even anti faith
either right faith may be a different
language for saying the same thing just
like you could ask me a question in
French or Arabic or German or anything
else it would still be the same question
that you just asked is just you know set
in a different way for the folks that
know how to speak that language so arts
arts are major deal and and look they
they've been so inspirational right so
many people have said in speech
recognition things like Star Trek and
inspire them as well
because again they put it in art and it
depicted what a future world might look
like and then guess what
for many of the folks in the audience
they view it as just you know something
that's fantastical right and yet for
some folks sitting there little kids
boys and girls and what have you that
are watching it they're like hey that's
not make-believe
I know how to build that I think I I
take this piece and then I'm put it with
that piece and I do it with that piece
or I need to learn this or I need to
learn that or I need to talk to this
mentor and then sure enough 10 20 30
years later they're giving birth to that
thing that they imagined long ago that's
that's what's wonderful about about
innovation yeah I love it
describe that aliens believer
non-believer I think they're real I
think there was a film that Carl Sagan
was involved which is it would be an
awfully waste waste of space if you will
so plausible but too big for them to
encounter and then you also have to
think of the of the lifetimes right in
the lifespan of whether we can be in
parallel with them one of the
mind-blowing things you have to realize
is all of the historical characters that
you know of in the past so think of your
Caesar is your Hannibal's your
you know Peter the peter the great's
George Washington's and everything else
these are only 1% of all humans that
ever lived were all the past humans 99%
of humans haven't existed yet they're
still in our future so there's a lot
more to do in their future then then
there's water under our bridge yet and
so they may be the ones that discover it
but you know to think that the first 1%
have discovered them I'm gonna chirp the
timeline so on or not but again I'm not
the expert in that yeah it's a lot of
people come on and they basically say it
would be selfish of us to think that
we're the only species in the galaxy and
it's so big and math and probability and
all this stuff but very few people talk
about it doesn't mean that it all has to
be simultaneous either right there
definitely can be other species on other
planets just they happened a million
years ago right or intelligence right or
our definition of intelligent life right
had have you visited here a million
years ago you wouldn't have your
definition of intelligent life and who
knows you know million years in the
future we may not have that anymore when
they are right so we have we have no
idea yeah it's um sometimes I read in
the news things like these two galaxies
are are colliding right now and in four
billion years our galaxy is gonna find
another one here just like that scares
the [ __ ] out of me frankly right yeah I
worry more about the galaxies colliding
in November 2020 now than anything else
and I hope on the other side of that you
know we have you know leaders that care
about all all citizens which would be
great and by the way all citizens I mean
all citizens worldwide all right because
this is this pandemic is a perfect
reminder that our our systems of
governance are interconnected right and
so we got a look at those this South
thing in a systemic way for sure what
one question do you have for me to to
wrap up here yeah so so you you've
obviously seen you know some of the best
of these future FinTech platforms that
are up and coming what really what
really excites you about the possibility
of those platforms in solving some of
the issues that were seeing with this
pandemic somehow you know had they been
applied correctly how would they be
responding to this crisis differently
yeah I think there's two core trends
that I see one doesn't get talked about
that much except for in crypto and then
the other gets talked about a lot so the
first one is just this idea of like you
and I have a certain set of banking
services that is commonplace I guess
table stakes right we can't imagine not
having a credit card or a debit card or
being able to go into a bank branch and
all these things and that's not the norm
globally right so there's a whole group
of people who just they kind of leapfrog
they went from zero banks to mobile
banking so you see it's all across like
the African continent but there's still
a lot of people who have no access to
banking services at all right they're
simply just a cash play society they get
paid in cash they hold cash etc and so
getting those people on boarded into you
know some sort of banking services
whether it looks more like the
traditional world or it's more crypto
based just that is really good I think
for a kind of human production when you
give people access to things like credit
and all that investment opportunities
etc so that's one bucket and then the
second bucket is actually the education
side so I think it's pretty clear we've
all identified like hey we don't teach
financial education in schools very well
I can understand how money works and all
that in some weird way I've told people
that things like Bitcoin cryptocurrency
and even washing technology to some
degree people come in through the
speculative nature right so there's a
lot of volatility there's price
movements there's a lot of people who
say oh I think I can go get rich right
now in the stock market same thing right
lots of volatility people either gonna
make a lot of money or lose a lot of
money and so when they start to actually
be drawn in through these volatile price
movements they begin to get educated
right and and and that almost drives the
education is driven by the speculation
in some weird way and so I think that
that's something we know that the
education is a problem but we don't
necessarily think through like well how
do we solve it on like a mass scale
and you know
it's a hard problem right because
frankly it's not just let me teach you
about how to open a bank account or let
me teach you you know about a balance
sheet there's an ever moving target you
know so I joke and I say if you were a
teacher teaching financial education at
a university or online or something the
the conversation you were having in
January and February of this year is
very different than the conversation
you'd be having right now and it's
because all the market conditions change
and so what could have been good advice
or good you know kind of lesson in
january/february actually may be
horrible now or it could be good right
but but the environment really matters
and something that's so dynamic like an
economy etc it's just something I just
pay attention to because I think if you
can you know educate folks then it's
very similar to you know AI machine
learning can give people the tools
you're surprised by what they kind of
end up doing and so I think it's pretty
important yeah it's best to give them
the tools when there's not an emergency
right because like you said there are
experiences that are worked by just
dealing with these emergencies that may
just be Black Swan events instead of
saying hey it's a normal part of your
operating system if you will to know how
to manage these affairs and by the way
this is how you put things away from a
rainy day by the way you'll be doing
that for a decade or two decades so that
one that Black Swan exists they'll
they'll you know fils through now your
backstop if you will and maybe you'll be
able to you know make your rent for
three six twelve months because you've
you've done this small you know put away
the small tokens if you will over over
time that turned into this this next
Nesta give you will because you know we
can show them hey every person's life is
going to experience X number of these
Black Swan events and you're gonna be
more resilient when they happen no
you're you're right it should be in in
the same way that we talk about you know
you know stem or steam right to add the
Arts in there that needs to be a
fundamental part of certainly education
in a capitalist society if not any
society right because resilience starts
with you and then it works with the
people around you and then it works with
with the system but you have to have
strong links of the chain across the
board and then we only help folks where
you know disaster truly struck and
there's nothing that
could have done to prevent it and that's
um you know we have a lot a lot more
folks that were affected then probably
should have been because of that lack of
education that you you said so the
system failed them then right yeah I
said the other day and I understand this
is unpopular but I do believe it which
is the people who are comfortable right
now and are likely the ones that will
thrive coming out of this economic
situation are the ones who did the hard
unpopular disciplined things for the
last you know two three four or five
years or so you know if you were getting
highly over-leveraged and you were doing
a bunch of speculating and kind of hey
I'm so you know I'm a genius cuz
everything keeps going up and you didn't
do the discipline things then you're
actually probably one of the people
who's likely to be in a batter or worse
position now right so it's this weird
thing where well that doesn't help to
identify today right because that means
that you would have had to do the things
previously but it is an explanation as
to why some people are actually
comfortable right now and other people
are you know kind of sweating bullets
and very worried right and briefly so
well I usually tell people look even as
children we were read the story of the
three little piggies alright so build it
out of straw build it out of wood or
build it out of break that was always
your choice right and whether that's
your career whether it's your education
whether it's your nest egg whatever you
were doing you know you know should have
you know and maybe that was too abstract
for people to get but it was always you
know build a plan so you can you can
operate with no revenue you know in this
company that's what we did you know find
a difference different sorts of
customers right so that if you lose one
sort of customers you still have that
build a different a diversity of
partners so that if you lose one you get
this other raise more you know
investment than you think you need right
by even 2x because you never know what
will happen so think of you know think
of the Gen Xers out there right Gen Xers
are you know um you know a group of
folks that people don't talk about about
a lot but we experienced the tail end of
the Cold War
then we experienced the boom and bust of
the first calm craze and then we
nine eleven and then we have 2008 and
now we have the pandemic right so it's
hit after hit after hit after hit in
some ways and and most of the folks that
I know in that field are actually very
serious folks and maybe it was you know
you know because of all the experiences
that they had that even the Boomers
didn't have it in some way so you know I
have yet to meet you know you know Gen X
or maybe that's why we listen to music
that was so down and and dark in some
ways too but yeah I think we'll make it
through I think if we stay innovative
and in an imply through IO is saying
just like Bill Gates right the the you
asked about favorite books but typically
a lot of the things that that um we
think about in some ways is you'll
always have a lot more folks that build
sand castles that knock them down and as
long as that's the case then you know
we'll make it through this and it'll be
better bigger and better
unfortunately in humanity we have to
experience floods and tornadoes and
hurricanes and earthquakes before we
learn to how to backstop them and
prepare for the next one and and we
needed a modern example of a pandemic in
order to realize you know we need it to
be more battle-hardened for this
particular event reality and so you know
we'll get to the other side of it and we
have to help as many folks as we can
through that transition yeah I
definitely agree where are where can
people find you online if they want to
reach out more about prion sure our
twitter handle is at prion so PR y ou n
is a Nancy and I'm at I J a B L okay o V
also on Twitter listen I really
appreciate taking the time to do this
you are one of if not the smartest
person I know when it comes to a lot of
this technology so I am obviously
cheering for you and I think people
learn a lot from this I appreciate doing
it yeah stay safe for everybody